[Music]
Thanks
captain
I just show me how to work this thing
well the turning thing there makes the
songs go up and down made by primitive
people that is producing my favorites
that's got traffic that's really good
they have some good songs Thin Lizzy is
a group I like a lot there's a lady on
there named Alice Cooper that I like a
lot seems kind of angry but kind of like
stuff how we felt were kids you know
[Music]
Peter consider this a token of a father
cried
memorial war over Zenda
when you single-handedly saved the
galaxy single-handedly it's perfect
you're kidding me right why am i dead
why did you all kill me tracks
that's Roman that's you
when was I that tiny you were never that
tiny what are you talking about I'm
looking at me you own a planet and can
destroy two dozen spaceships without a
suit what are you exactly
just who do you think
[Music]
you are a garden of the galaxy guardians
of the galaxy
why would we be the guardians of the
galaxy oh so stupid the Ravagers the
sovereign
they want to take over the galaxy so
we're saving the galaxy again I get it
[Music]
I see it within you fear betrayal or any
of you do is yell at each other
stupid raccoons star much you're right
we're family
Showtime a-holes
[Music]
[Applause]
beautiful
Haigh what about this little plant can I
smash it with a rock no it's too
adorable to care
[Applause]
[Music]